let's keep doing the first problem from
the 2008 calculus bc exam we're on part
b
we're on part b
part b i think that's too thick
okay it says the horizontal line y
equals negative 2
splits the region r this is r
into two parts
right but do not evaluate an integral
expression for the area of the part of r
that is below the horizontal line so
let's draw y is equal to negative 2. so
y equals negative 2 would look like this
why it's just a constant
that's not thick enough i don't know if
you can see that let me do it as a thick
line
and then a
darker color maybe
y is equal to negative two will look
something like
that
and what they they're saying is that it
splits this region onto two parts right
this part and this part and what they
want to know is
an integral expression for the area of
the part of r that is below the
horizontal line so they care about the
area of this part of r
and remember they just want us to
write the expression not evaluate it so
that'll hopefully save us time so how do
we figure this out
well the easy part is actually to figure
out what the expression we're going to
take the definite integral of and it's
going to be a little bit harder to
figure out the boundary points so what
is what is the the expression within the
definite integral that we'll use well
just like we did in part a think about
we're going to take a sum of a bunch of
rectangles
and the height of the rectangles is
going to be the difference
between the two functions
right
and this is y is equal to negative two
and then this function right here is y
is equal to and we had written it down
in part three but that's x cubed minus
4x that's this curve right here
so the height of each of these little
rectangles is going to be
-2
minus
x to the third
minus 4 x that's the height of each of
these rectangles and then the width of
each of those rectangles we know
from
well just learning calculus or learning
integrals the width is dx we're going to
multiply that times dx and then we're
going to take all of the sums from x is
equal to whatever this point is to
whatever this point is so we need to
figure out
this point this value of x which is
going to be here and then this value of
x which is going to be there and so
these are really just two of the points
where these two func where this function
where these two functions intersect each
other so how do we figure out those
points what we could do is we can set
them equal to each other so we could say
at what x values does
x to the third
minus four x
equal minus two right at what x values
are the y values the same
right so we just set them equal to each
other and we let's see if we wanted to
write this as a proper polynomial
expression we would get
x to the third
minus 4x
plus 2 is equal to zero and i actually
just tried to do record a video where i
was doing this on the fly and i kept
staring at this and i was like boy this
is a this is a hard polynomial to factor
i kept trying to guess numbers or
figuring out i even tried to do newton's
method and i kept getting weird numbers
and i i became suspicious of myself
and then i looked at the actual test
actually i could show it to you
and it says a graphing says right there
a graphing calculator is required for
some problems or parts of problems and i
realize that they probably want us to
use a graphing calculator to figure out
the roots of this polynomial so let's do
that it's been a long time since i
actually took
ap calculus and i and now i remember
that a graphing calculator was a big
deal
so let's use this i just actually
downloaded this ti 85 emulator
so let's use this to figure out the
roots of this polynomial so let's turn
it on
and let's see if we want to figure out
the roots we use the poly function so
second
poly
what's the order of this polynomial
what's a third degree polynomial right
it has an x to the third so order is
three
enter
and what are the coefficients
well the coefficient on the x to the
third term is one
go down
what's the coefficient on the x squared
term
well there is no x squared term right so
that coefficient is zero
go down
what's the coefficient on the x term
it's minus four
right
so minus four
go down again
and then the coefficient or the constant
term well that's just going to be 2
and now we can just hit
solve
let's see
and we get three crazy numbers and this
shows you that this would have been very
hard to solve analytically
using
if you have a normal brain so let's see
there are three places where y equals
negative two intersects
y
is equal to x to the third minus 4x it
intersects at minus
2.21 but that's off of this graph that's
not even here right that's somewhere off
to the left this curve probably comes
back down and intersects over there at
-2 but it also intersects at 1.675
which is
probably right here right that looks
like 1.675 it also intersects at 0.539
which is right there so we can use those
values
that our graphing calculator gave us and
put it into
our integral our definite integral so
this point
so this point right here
our polynomial solver told us is x is
equal to .539
so we'll put here point
five
three
nine
and then this point right here so this
is our limits of integration for our
definite integral right we're going to
take sum up these little
these little rectangles from x is equal
to 0.539 to x is equal to
1.675
so 2 1.6
and they told us that they do not want
us to evaluate it so we are done with
part b we could just write this and we
should hopefully get full credit
maybe they'd want you to simplify this a
little bit but i'd be surprised if they
were to mark off for that anyway
let's do part c
if we have time
part c
so they say the region r is the base of
a solid for this solid each cross
section perpendicular to the x-axis is a
square find the volume of solid okay so
this is interesting so that same let me
see if i can draw it so that curve i'm
going to draw it kind of with a
perspective so you can see the solid
they're talking about
so that it's the same region r so we had
a sine function on the top
it looks something like that
and then we had that polynomial function
on the bottom that looks something like
that
i'm trying to draw it at an angle let me
see if i can
so just to show you the x-axis
let me draw you the x-axis
this is going to be the x-axis
that's the x-axis
let me draw the y-axis
the y-axis the way i do it now it looks
something like this
try and do a little bit of perspective
so that we can
visualize what they're talking about
so that's the y-axis so that's x
y and what they're saying this is the
region r again just like in the pre-part
previous two parts of the problem
and say the region r is the base of a
solid right so this is the base of a
solid for this solid each cross section
perpendicular to the x-axis so a cross
section perpendicular to the x-axis
let's see if we can draw that
so this would be a cross-section so it's
like we took a knife and we cut like
this we cut parallel to the y axis
so if we took a cross section
say we took this cross section
of this solid right now
they say that it is a square so that
means that the base has to be the same
height as it has to be the same dis
size as the height so if we took the
cross section of the solid here would be
like that
here would be us be a smaller square
like that if we took the cross section
there it'd be a small square as well oh
i think i'm messing up my pen
be a small square as well
so what they want us to do is figure out
the volume of solid you can kind of
imagine what it looks like it's small
squares and the squares get really big
and then they get small again so how do
we do that
well we do the same thing
we take the area
of each of these squares we know they're
squares times each of the
dx's
right
the small differential and we sum them
up
over the from zero to two right we on
the first diagram that said that was two
oh and i'm about to be out of time so i
will continue this problem in the next
video see you soon